[Musica]
buon pomeriggio sono un ex danzatrice
professionista ho lavorato nei teatri
alla scala e su palchi internazionali
sono diventata una madre ho dato vita a
due figlie marianna cecilia ho raggiunto
un secondo momento creando un'azienda è
un brand di abbigliamento e accessori
queste premesse perché mi posso definire
una creativa
proprio per questo mi sento di
riflettere insieme a voi su due parole
che mi stanno a cuore
ricreare e ricrearsi la radice del verbo
che è creare è greca rayon vuol dire
progettare fare realizzare
c'è una parte sanscrita che carta che
vuol dire colui che crea dal nulla che
quindi è proprio a partire da zero fare
dove non c'era questo quello che è
l'umanità ha fatto per secoli in questo
momento storico
ritengo che sia importante soffermarsi
sull'evoluzione del del verbo creare e
andare sulla parola ricreare ovvero fare
qualcosa ricomponendo e usando quello
che c'è abbiamo già intorno a noi tutto
quello che è necessario
penso che ci sia una grande abbondanza
di natura manufatti bellezza e possiamo
andare avanti da lì
ho perso mia madre da piccola ho perso
la mia sorella gemella nel modo peggiore
possibile prima dei 20 anni o con un
banalissimo incidente ho dovuto
rinunciare una carriera professionista
di danzatrice che per me era come
respirare
ho perso pezzi persone care e capacità
fisiche ho dovuto fermarmi ricompormi
ricre armi per poter continuare a vivere
ho fatto tesoro delle passioni delle
persone care degli amici e delle mie
capacità
ho raccolto i pezzi attingendo a quello
che avevo
ho fatto una lista delle cose che avevo
mi sono detta da dove partiamo
ha una sensibilità artistica e creativa
sono italiana penso di avere nel dna
amore per bellezza cultura sensibilità
ce l'abbiamo tutti quanti noi sono
tenace sono friulana e appartengo una
cultura un popolo di confine a cui è
stato sottratto molto nei secoli e che
ha risvegliato nelle persone tenacia e
resilienza ho avuto degli esempi ho
avuto mia madre uno spirito veramente
gioioso che dal nulla
eccola qua senza mezzi non aveva soldi
pochi tessuti è diventata una modellista
e una sarta bravissima usando la carta
quello che vedete carta ho avuto
l'esempio di mio padre che mi ha
insegnato molto e mi ha insegnato che
potevo diventare essere e progettare
quello che volevo senza paura
questa libertà mi ha permesso di andare
in giro per il mondo in modo veramente
improbabile da sola non ho mai avuto
paura di niente mi sono trovate in
situazioni veramente divertentissimi e
molto improbabili
avete presente sempre tornando al pop il
film di indiana jones
quando arrivano alla reggia del maharaja
e offrono una cena fatta di robe
incredibili serpenti
io ho una volta ho preso un cucchiaio da
una zuppa e ho trovato dentro gli occhi
quella scena lissimo mi sono divertita
tantissimo però non ho solo urlato come
l'attrice
un'ultima cosa su cui ho potuto contare
e che mi riesce bene organizzare mi
piace lavorare con gli altri mi piace
fare con le mani e utilizzare strumenti
o una passione per le cassette degli
attrezzi ben organizzate in questo
curioso modo a 38 anni ho creato un
brand è una piccola azienda di
abbigliamento
gazelle partendo da una volontà che era
quella di inventarmi mescolare le mie
carte e ricombinarli mi sono trovata in
un mondo bellissimo super stimolante
però molto competitivo che ha delle
regole e delle modalità di lavoro ben
rodate precise
vi spiego molto brevemente che cosa vuol
dire creare mettere insieme una
collezione di moda devi partire da
un'immagine da un'idea un'ispirazione si
chiama mood poi passi a fare i disegni
tutti diciamogli i figurini da lì in poi
vai a cercare i tessuti li fai produrre
per rispondere alla tua idea e poi fai
produrre del prodotto dei capi di
abbigliamento di borse o di quant'altro
e li metti sul mercato anche la mia
azienda ha seguito per molti anni questo
questo processo che è lungo e laborioso
perché volevamo imparare dai più bravi
da quelli che facevano meglio di noi
siamo arrivati però a un punto in cui
c'è una criticità
i filtri non funzionano più è un sistema
che non
sta più funzionando la produzione in
questo momento sta attingendo a risorse
ea energie che non sono più così
disponibili e inoltre stiamo immettendo
sul mercato una quantità di prodotto che
non è più sostenibile
il concetto è il valore del consumismo
non tiene più è un valore che ci sta
veramente distruggendo in un in un
settore che per eccellenza creativo
ritengo che sia il momento giusto in cui
ripensare la parola e diventare i
creativi
dobbiamo creare dal ricreare mi sono
chiesta come applicare questo pensiero
nel mio lavoro nel lavoro che stavo
facendo e sono ho deciso di partire dai
materiali invece che dalle idee sono
partita per le fabbriche sono andata a
cercare in tutti i magazzini gli avanzi
di produzione che in italia parlando di
tessile sono meravigliosi abbiamo
grandissima qualità chiusa nei magazzini
ho raccolto tutti questi materiali sul
tavolo li ho disposti le li ho ri
assemblati e con una volontà creativa
ho messo insieme quella che era una
collezione di moda di abbigliamento ho
battezzato questa seconda su questa
linea con un nome che si chiama second
life
questo processo di assemblare tessuti
alla fine attenzione crea solo abiti non
ha altre velleità no no non ho la
pretesa di essere un ingegnere che salva
la vita come alla pollo 13 però questo
riflette secondo me una mentalità che se
noi possiamo diciamo utilizzare ea
adattare i nostri stili di vita e
lavorare con quello che c'è possiamo
dare nuova vita a quello che ci circonda
molto semplicemente
i consumatori sono già pronti e alla
ricerca di prodotti che abbiano dentro
di sé questo valore
ho scelto anche il termine second life
perché ritengo che tutti noi voi stessi
abbiate crisi secondo vite avete a siete
arrivati a secondo vite avete avuto dei
cambiamenti
chi ha cambiato città chi lavoro chi
relazioni e non è sempre stato un
cambiamento a farci le immagino non è
scontato e faticoso e allo stesso tempo
e stimolante ricreare la propria vita
non è una passeggiata e ci cambia ea
però qualcosa di significativo ci porta
verso il futuro sono anche italiana e
parlo sempre di cibo come tanti di noi
mi vengono in mente le volte in cui si
arriva a casa si apre il frigorifero e
ci sono gli avanzi e si mettono insieme
le cene con quello che che c'è poi chi è
bravo che ha la fortuna di essere un
bravo cuoco riesce a fare delle
meraviglie penso anche spesso alle cene
degli avanzi quelle che si fanno con gli
amici
dopo le feste ognuno di noi porta
qualcosa sul tavolo mescola al cibo crea
qualcosa di diverso di più interessante
e soprattutto condivide e mette insieme
qualcosa che dà piacere a tutti quanti
mi piace anche riflettere a un'ultima
accezione della parola ricreare perché
non vuol dire soltanto creare di nuovo
rifondare ricostituire ma anche
divertire provo procurando riposo e
svago questo viene dal dizionario
mi piace pensare al futuro e alle future
attività imprenditoriali come
ricreazioni che abbiano in sessi al
accezione positiva del
riprodurre rifondare ma che abbiano
dentro anche il significato di
alleggerire portare piacere e
divertimento
la leggerezza e il piacere del fare e
del vivere sono quelle che ci
permetteranno di affrontare le sfide che
abbiamo davanti
che sono tante senza paura di cambiare
con coraggio divertendoci e pensando che
tutto sia possibile grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]